Okay, so based on these answers, I know that 1 half is equal to 2 4ths. I also
know that one half is equal to 3 6th. So how exactly did I do that? How did I
change this into this? Well, if I look at this shape and this one, I notice that
I just doubled the number of pieces that are in this shape. And I doubled the
number of pieces that I have shaded. So I doubled both. The numerator and the
denominator, and I got 1 times 2 which is 2 and 2 times 2 which is 4 or 2 4ths.
Now let's look between the one half and the 3 6ths. This time I took my shaded
pieces and I tripled them, so I multiplied them by 3. I also took the total
number of pieces, I had 2. And now I have a total number of pieces of 6. So I
also tripled my number of pieces. 1 times 3 is 3. And 2 times 3 is 6. But let's
think about why we can do this. I know 2 divided by 2 is really just 1. So I'm
just multiplying one half by a form of 1. I'm not changing the value one half.
I'm just changing what the fraction looks like. The same is true down here. I'm
taking one half and multiplying it by a different form of 1. And I'll get 3
6ths. So we know one half is equal to 2 4ths which is equal to 3 6ths. These are
all equivalent fractions. Okay, but let's look a little bit closer at this 2
over 2 and 3 over 3.